It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU BAU!
And today we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Good morning!
Thank you for joining us today for our 149th episode!
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
One episode before the big milestone!
BAU BAU!
149th!
So soon!
Ruffians!
What do you think?
Are you proud of us?
You are praised already!
Is that not allowed?
149 episodes!
It's just about approaching our 150th episode!
But any Ruffians who maybe this is your first episode.
Well, FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday.
A.K.A FUWAMOCO!
And it's hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw!
Yeah!
Okay, got that!
Now!
You know what I'm gonna say, but I'll tell you anyway!
What are you gonna say, Moco-chan?
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag!
Hashtag FWMCMORNING!
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Thank you Ruffians.
Nice big BAU BAU.
You know it's just about the weekend.
Exciting weekend.
Moco-chan.
We have some exciting things to share with the Ruffians, right?
Nothing like a Pero Sighting, right?
Pero.
Wait, huh?
Ruffians!
You ain't looking forward to a Pero Sighting, are you?
Pero doko?
Is that like a doko?
I want to know doko!
You need to lulu us for the thing!
Because it shouldn't be like that, Ruffians.
Pero is still alive.
He's a demon dog.
That question, I can't tell if you want it or don't.
I guess you just want the facts, huh?
Moco-chan, was there a Pero Sighting?
There was a Pero Sighting.
BAU BAU!
Let's take a look!
Ruffians, where did you see Pero this time?
De-den!
Pero, about hiding in our- You both.
Ruffians!
Are you hallucinating?
Are you seeing things that don't exist?
Ruffians, there's no way Pero's hiding or has ever seen it in our fluff and fuzz before.
Never ever.
Not our tails.
Pero does it again.
What do you mean does it again?
We're clean demon dogs.
Yeah.
Our ears aren't nasty.
No, no, no.
We have fuzz.
Maybe Moco-chan has her fuzz, but... No nasty.
No Pero.
Why do we have Pero in our- Ruffians.
Pero's not there.
You're seeing things.
Ruffians!
No.
Well, it's a good thing.
I think it's good that you can take a break.
And, uh, maybe during that break time, you can go and, uh, get your eyes checked!
Yeah!
Uh.
Huh?
You can't ask to pet him.
He's not there.
Yeah.
BAU BAU!
Got it!
Your eyes are fine.
I disagree.
Like to differ.
Time to go to the doctor.
BAU BAU!
Wow!
We have some exciting news!
FUWAMOCO!
I released a brand new cover song a few weeks ago of Ayaka's Crescent Moon!
BAU BAU!
Thanks to your Ruffians, it just reached 250k views on YouTube!
Thank you!
This time it's the English version of a Japanese song called Mikazuki.
I know I've talked about it before, but even though it can be hard to believe, it's very difficult for us hololive EN members to cover songs in English.
So we're really happy to finally be able to sing a song in English.
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
FUWAMOCO Sing it with.
FUWAMOCO Congratulations!
Thank you!
We'll continue to do our best!
Practice our singing so you know we can improve and hopefully reach you even more through our voice too!
Thank you!
Love you!
Bye bye!
Thank you!
I think there's going to be some voice singing going on because very soon, Yara-senpai is going to be having a very special 3D
Spring Party coming up!
BAU BAU!
It's gonna be on April 20th and at 5pm PT.
So we hope that you'll join over on Kiara-senpai's channel.
You know, this time it's a bit different.
This time it's a concert with only EN members as guests.
And actually, also only features songs from an idol agency famous for groups like Anusha if you heard Morning Musumen.
Yeah, the idol agency Hello Project.
Yeah, Hello Project.
It's okay.
Yeah!
Hello Project Morning Musume!
But Kiara-senpai is a very big fan of Hello Project, or HP.
Yeah!
And FUWAMOCO, we are too, I think, much more casual.
We didn't have an oshi in particular.
A bit more hako-oshi.
Oh, you know, you like everybody.
Yeah!
So actually!
FUWAMOCO.
We're extremely excited to be also invited as guests together in Advent too!
Yeah!
BAU BAU!
FUWAMOCO!
Yeah!
One time I became eggs recently, huh?
That's amazing But you know... That's exciting!
Exciting, yes I did it
FU
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Morning Musume.
Matsura Aya.
You know, obviously, we're really excited for you!
Please come join us, okay?
We hope you'll check it out, okay?
FUWAMOCO!
Dancing and singing together with Kiara-senpai!
BAU BAU!
Exciting, yeah!
You're not familiar with the whole project?
After Kiara-senpai's spring party, maybe it won't be that hard.
BAU BAU!
Eh?
A big news going on!
Big news!
This is something I'm really excited about.
Right!
Big news!
Hoho Ien!
Wow!
You might be finding some of us at sushi restaurants across America!
Because there's gonna be a special collab started in July 2025 at Kura Sushi in the U.S.!
This time it's featuring Ura-senpai, Saki-senpai, and Gigi!
So you know, if you go to Kurasushi right now, it's around $70.
Right now?
Yeah, I'm pretty sure it's already going on.
Coming July 2025.
Yeah, that's when they get serious about it, you know.
Why?
But right now, if you spend around $70, you can get an extra special exclusive gear pass.
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Have a howl of a day!
We will talk about sushi at 8am if it involves Ina-senpai, Korone-senpai, and GD!
I'm really excited!
It's just starting to heat up a little bit, you know?
I'm sure there'll be a lot more coming out once it gets closer to the summer time.
Summer equals sushi.
Yeah.
So, Ruffians!
I hope that you're ready to eat some good sushi and grapple!
Yeah, you know, the exclusive gear pass.
Yeah, this sushi collab is made in the U.S.A!
By the way, Ruffians, I think I see a lot of questions.
FUWAMOCO's favorite sushi.
Moco-chan.
Tuna.
Salmon.
The Basics.
Inari Sushi.
I like the hotate.
I like saying hotate more than eating hotate.
Hotate!
Yeah.
Perfect choices.
Unagi is good too, yeah!
But unagi sushi can't really find in Japan, right?
I don't know.
I have a book.
Yeah.
But exciting!
Please keep your eyes out, okay?
You know, asking them to check their eyes again?
Yeah.
This is third time.
BAU BAU!
Ruffians!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Okayu-senpai!
She released a very special visual novel game for Okayu-nyuumu!
A visual novel where she's the heroine, the main character, you know, and maybe you kind of fall in love with her.
We don't know.
We don't know because up until now it's only been released in Japanese, but it was just announced that Okayu-nyuumu...
Okayu Ryoma is going to be coming out in English!
BAU BAU!
And also available on Steam this summer!
We're really excited!
If you don't know already, FUWAMOCO really like visual novels.
If you've never heard of a visual novel, what's that?
A book?
It is a game.
It's a game, not a book.
It's not a book, and you know, it's a very good story!
Visuals!
Music!
And you know, there's multiple choices so you get to control the story until it's right!
It's a game because you click yes and you enjoy it.
You know, but we've heard a lot of things about Wakai and Yumu.
Uh, maybe it's a little bit spicy at times.
Why is it so funny?
Why talk to Ako-senpai about playing her version of a song?
She's embarrassing.
Why talk to Karin-senpai about playing it?
She was not.
She's excited!
She's like, yes, please!
FUWAMOCO, yes!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
FUWAMOCO is one of our big dreams.
Our big goal is to release our own visual novel one day.
And actually, that's what we want to use our 1 million wish for.
In case you've forgotten.
But that's still TBD, TBD.
Haven't heard anything.
TBD, TBA.
What's the other ones?
All the ones.
But continue working towards that dream!
I think slowly, but surely!
To be continued.
BAU BAU!
Exciting!
Why are you exciting?
Okay, Moco-chan.
Ruffians!
It's actually been a few styling.
Update to FUWAMOCO!
Huh?
Have you noticed anything Ruffians?
Have you noticed?
I don't think any Ruffians noticed.
I don't think they have.
Oh no.
Yeah.
Sometimes the Ruffians don't notice.
Sometimes I was like a weirdo, but sometimes I'm really really cute.
It looks like we're gonna have to give a hint to the Ruffians, huh?
Here I go, Ruffians!
Big updates to FUWAMOCO!
De-den!
Well, first... De-den!
Moco-chan.
Where's Fuwawa?
Hi!
What does this mean?
I have my photo retaken.
You noticed!
Do I look cuter?
Do you notice a difference?
No.
Cute!
You look cuter!
Such change, you're even cuter!
I don't think the Ruffians realize.
I hear Fuwawa saying, oh cute it, cute it, but I don't see the Ruffians say that.
I'm seeing, I'm hearing it, but I'm not seeing it.
I think the Ruffians are just taking this opportunity to call you cute, huh, Moco-chan?
They should.
They should take the opportunity often.
But, but Moco-chan, I'm not getting replaced or anything, right?
No.
We're still gonna be...
Not, not Mocomoco.
Yeah.
Mocomoco.
No.
FUWAMOCO?
Yes.
Okay, good.
I was nervous when you said I'm not getting replaced, huh?
I don't know.
No, that was an affirmative no.
I'm not getting replaced, right?
And I said no.
What did I say wrong, Ruffians?
What did I say wrong?
I said the proper answers.
Yes, no.
No, you said I'm not getting replaced, right?
If I said yes, that means yes, you're getting replaced.
I don't know if that's how it works, Moco-chan.
Right!
Mococo is correct!
Yes!
Thank you!
Well, Ruffians, maybe later you can go and take a look at the photo.
With your eyes!
And see how much cuter Moco-chan has gotten!
Make sure your eyes are working just like after the Pero Sighting, huh?
Yeah, and everything else.
BAU BAU!
You can't see the difference!
You have to use your eyes better, okay?
Got it?
Got it, Moco-chan.
BAU BAU!
Ruffians, you know, I'm sure you realize, especially at the very beginning here, but the next episode of FUWAMOCO Morning is our 150th episode!
We're a very big milestone, and you know, we've had so many special mornings that we spent together.
Ruffians, you ready?
What does FUWAMOCO Morning mean to you?
We wanna hear mine from you, Ruffians!
How does your morning routine go with FUWAMOCO Morning?
What does it mean to you?
Like last time, but you know, it's been a little while, you know.
It's important for us, okay?
So, please let us know with the special hashtag.
Special hashtag.
Yes.
Hashtag FWMCMORNING150.
150!
Okay, Ruffians!
But, as you know, maybe we can celebrate it all together.
Maybe...
You know, share some of them as part of the celebration.
Yeah, please look forward to it, okay?
You know, being able to spend, you know, your morning together with us.
It means a lot to us, but we want to share more.
I wanna hear your stories, or maybe you know you had a really rough morning.
Is it okay for us to be a bit selfish like this?
It's not morning there?
That's okay!
It's a good morning in your heart!
Yeah, I wanna hear, what FUWAMOCO Morning means to you, Ruffians?
So please let us know on Twitter with the hashtag, okay?
It's right here.
We're looking forward to it.
Thank you all fans!
BAU BAU!
Moco-chan.
I think it's time for a very fluffy and fuzzy time of the day.
Yeah!
It's time for the Doggie of the Day!
Let's take a look at today's doggy.
De-den!
Today's Doggie of the Day is two doggies!
Max and Luddy!
Hi FUWAMOCO!
They're so silly!
Look at them!
That was funny.
Yeah, we do that sometimes too, huh Moco-chan?
It's hard to tell which is the puppy with more levels.
They both look so young.
Silly Cuddle Puddle!
But you know Max?
Max is the kind, older puppy.
And Woody!
Woody's still in training after, you know, some rough experiences.
But it's nice of Max, you know?
And you know, I'm sure Woody's doing great, you know?
Max is busy, you know?
FUWAMOCO in real life?
No!
This is FUWAMOCO in real life!
That's Max and Woody.
Don't get cut off the Max and Woody channel, okay?
Got it.
Moco-chan, how does Max BAU BAU?
Wow!
Cute!
I like that.
How does Woody BAU BAU Moco-chan?
Maybe Woody's not cooperating as much as we'd like?
Yeah.
A bit troublesome.
A bit of wolf.
You know.
Yeah.
That's okay, we'll get there.
Still in training.
But you know, I think just with one simple photo, we can clearly see that they're the best buddies you could ever wish for.
Yeah, very silly buddies!
And I think also we can kind of see that maybe they are a bit of a handful at times.
Maybe.
FUWAMOCO Good luck!
BAU BAU!
Sweet goggles, yeah!
Wow, Ruffians!
It's getting warmer and warmer.
Almost at the end of April.
You're going out for walks, right?
Let's take a look on today I went on a walk.
We have... De-den!
Water!
Oh my gosh, this is a photo of Sun Moon Lake.
That's a cool name.
Look at the water, it's so blue, green.
Ticklies!
Neat.
Wow.
Wow, this will be my paddle boarding.
That's a lot of upper body strength.
Yeah, you're brave.
Oh, it's such a gorgeous picture and nice walk.
Does this count as a walk?
This is a paddle.
A walk happened and then paddle.
Today I went on a paddle boarding.
Yes, that's yes, Moco-chan.
Canoe.
Is a paddleboard the same as a canoe?
I don't know.
Well, FUWAMOCO you know.
Well, we can't swim.
These demon dogs, we can swim.
But we're not too confident with our doggy paddle.
Good enough.
Yeah.
I hope you know there's a safety pride in case you know we kind of take a tumble off the sides there.
Do I float well enough?
Alright, well we'll figure that out if you get tossed in, huh?
Please don't toss me in!
Do not toss me in, okay?
What do you like more, the sun or the moon, Moco-chan?
I think I like the moon.
The moon is so pretty and it's not hot.
The moon, it makes us feel magical.
You know, it's something that kind of awakens a little bit.
But the sun is nice too.
The sun is nice, there's nothing wrong with the sun.
I just like the moon better.
That's all.
BAU BAU!
We hope you made it back to shore safely.
Thank you!
Thank you for taking us with you too.
Please take us everywhere with you Ruffians, okay?
Well, we also received a question from a Ruffian.
Let's take a look at the Question of the Day.
We have De-den!
Hey FUWAMOCO!
I'm heading to Japan in the near future and want to buy something as a souvenir.
For yourself?
Maybe for friends, but maybe for yourself?
If there's one hololive product or even something else that you can only get in Japan, what would you recommend?
BAU BAU!
We have no perfect answer for that, only in Japan.
Well, in Tokyo Station, right now there's the hololive Tokyo Character Street store.
There's a special Tokyo Character Street, a bunch of different stores within hololive.
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Spread things soon!
That is true too!
It might be soon!
I guess in the near future.
I don't know how near that is.
But also you know, maybe you're planning a trip to Akihabara.
We recommend going and visiting the Kotobukiya store!
There's a big hololive section!
And you know, you might be able to find something very special there as well!
And maybe FUWAMOCO
We'll be there at the register there to bring up your purchase.
We're so happy to be able to help out with the register at the Kotobukiyo.
In our special outfits too.
But you know we have heard from Ruffians that it is a little tricky to find FUWAMOCO merch in Japan in the wild sometimes.
Good luck looking!
Sorry!
BAU BAU!
Have fun!
Thank you so much, Muffians, for all your submissions!
Thank you!
You know, we're always looking for more Doggie of the Day's Pero Sightings questions and looks.
And you can send them to us with the hashtag, the usual hashtag #FWMCMORNING, but... Oh, I get that!
Because for our next special episode of episode 150 of FUWAMOCO Morning, we'd like you to share with us what FUWAMOCO Morning means to you with the hashtag.
Hashtag FWMCMORNING150!
150, okay?
Got it!
Yeah.
Just this one.
You can post right after this, yeah.
It's always good to do it before you forget.
Yeah.
Or you could do it down below.
Before you forget.
Thank you so much for being here!
BAU BAU!
Do we have another stream coming up, Moco-chan?
My next stream is on...
De-den!
FUWAMOCO Morning episode 1 debut!
FUWAMOCO is actually going to be going on our first mini vacation since debut.
So we're going to be going off and exploring Japan a little bit.
And we'll be back with FUWAMOCO Morning on April 28th.
A bunch of stories!
Maybe some photos and some recommendations too on places to visit!
So, we'll do our best!
We'll have lots of fun!
Okay!
Thank you, Ruffians!
We'll look forward to it!
Of course, we'll also be in Kyary-senpai's channel content as well!
I hope that you'll check that out too!
And hopefully we can also do a Twitter space during your time as well!
Hope for good wifi.
Yeah.
Thank you, Ruffians!
And for the Ruffians joining us in the archive today, your FUWAMOCO word is... It's BAU BAU traveling!
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for joining us for FUWAMOCO Morning today!
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
Photonic!
BAU BAU!
You!
YC!
BAU BAU!
Astro Vinyl!
FUWAMOCO Morning!
To every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!